okay so the Last of Us episode 3 has
just dropped and in this video we're
going to be breaking down the new entry
talking about the Easter eggs in it and
all the changes to the game whereas the
last two weeks have had us following the
footsteps of Joel and Ali this one takes
a big detour not only do we focus on
Bill and Frank's relationship but they
also massively alter the way the things
happen in the game now the first thing I
want to do is go through Bella's story
in the PlayStation classic for anyone
who hasn't played it this will kind of
give you an idea of just how much things
were changed and what we originally had
first time round as always we will be
saving future spoilers for the end of
the video and if you enjoy it then
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day by the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the last of us three
now in the game you arrive in Lincoln
having just escaped the state building
this culminated in Tessa's death and
Joel and Ali fled into the Subway after
being chased by Federer you never really
got to catch your breath and on the
other side of this when you slowed down
Jill refused to talk about Tess this
showed just how cold he was and even
upon reaching Bill he just played along
that she was alive without ever
correcting him now the way that Joel and
Ali met with him was that they sprung
one of his traps which led to Joe being
suspended upside down in one of the
tensor scenes in the game sworn by
infected you had to defend yourself in
Ellie as they tried to tear you apart
this is when bill came in and after
making your way to his church you laid
low for a beer before Manning a plan to
get a truck battery this was from a
military Caravan that had crashed into a
nearby School in an area that Bell
normally refused to go to this was due
to that side of town being teeming with
infected but because he owed Joel a
favor they decided to head out there
overloaded with infected you found that
the battery had already been taken and
he had to burst you to school before or
making it to a neighborhood and after
stumbling across a house you'll learn to
take in the battery and this was Belle's
ex Frank who had made a break for it
unlike the show Frank couldn't stand
Bill anymore and when the Caravan
crashed he devised the planet take the
battery on the way out though he'd been
bitten and he ended up unaliving himself
before the infection took its toll he
left a note behind for bells saying how
much he hated him and after finding his
truck you pop the clutch and headed out
to Pittsburgh now that's the way the
game played out with it being heavily
focused on action and a massive
deviation from what we get here I will
be going through How Stuff compares to
the game as we get into it but that's
kind of a bird's eye view of how it
plays out so you can instantly see how
different it is to the show now we begin
with Jill dipping his hand into a river
and there's a tension drawn of the cuts
on his knuckles from smashing that God's
face and like it's the like button Ellie
very much represents the daughter that
he couldn't save and the lesson that he
learned from this is the wrong one and
he might end up thinking that violence
is the way to achieve things I suppose
if probably is the right lesson in this
world but he clearly wrestles with
losing his cool like this now this idea
of losing one's control is juxtaposed by
the stone stacking that we see him
carrying out typically you'd see
something like this in a spa and stone
stackings carried out because it has a
spiritual connection to the Earth but
also takes time and effort to create the
balance in the pile and this Stone
stacking seen as being someone that
showcases one's patience however it goes
beyond that and it's a practice that's
being carried out in several cultures
dating all the way back to ancient
Mongolia Stone Stacks were also used for
navigation in rural areas due they're
not being signed posts or roads out in
the woods or by Rivers I think it's more
for the former reason but I I just
thought I'd bring that up too now
they're 10 miles outside of Boston in
the woods which is a location that you
start up at before traveling into
Lincoln Ellie's now wearing a green coat
with a red hoodie and this is something
that she'd done later on in the game
once we hit the winter sections though
Joel's pretty [__] off from her I like
the touch that they've added here which
is that she's using his jacket for a
blanket at this point he's still really
from the death of Tess but due to being
a closed Buck he refuses to open up he
still clearly cares though and he tosses
her some food which leads into a
conversation that plays out slightly
differently in the game it kind of
change up the positioning of the lines
and Joel says not to bring up Tess here
whereas he does it at the end of the
episode in the show
hey look
um
about Tess
listen about Tess
I don't even know here's how this
thing's gonna play out
you don't bring up Tess
ever
rule one you don't bring up tests ever
in fact we just keep our histories to
ourselves matter of fact we can just
keep our histories to ourselves
secondly
don't tell anybody about your condition
well too you don't tell anyone about
your
condition they think you're crazy
they'll try to kill you you see that by
Mark they won't think it through they'll
just shoot you
and lastly you do what I say when I say
it rule three
say when I say it
we clear
repeat it
sure repeat it
what you say goes
good
okay either way Joel is completely shut
off and they hike for four hours before
passing through the woodlands one of the
things that's never really touched upon
about the last of us is how much it
focuses on the beauty of Nature and how
once Humanity's been whittled down the
Earth can reclaim the land getting all
hippie here but uh cordyceps themselves
could very much be seen as a defense
mechanism for Earth and tying back at
the climate change comments this could
be the planet finding a way to get rid
of us without creating Skynet big Theory
time for that but Ellie asks Joe how he
got his scar and he says it's from the
early days when someone shot at him and
missed though he says that he shot back
it is possible that this could have come
from the night Sarah died and it may
have been a stray from The Soldier's
bullets the scars are beside his Temple
and I think this would explain a lot if
he was reminded of that night every time
he looked in the mirror and they
traveled to Cumberland Farms which
apparently is a real store in America so
I learned something about our cousins
every day this is a stash house where
gels Left Behind supplies but the real
talking Point here is the Mortal Kombat
2 cabinet Ellie mentions her friend he
knew everything about this game and this
is likely Riley who was touched upon in
episode 1. I can't tell you how much
money this machine Swallowed at amble
Caravan Park when I was a kid and me and
my cousin Mark used to spend most of our
time on a Saturday getting our asses
kicked by scorpion Ellie brings in
Milena and how she used to rip off her
mask to reveal her horrendous teeth
which is one of the most memorable
fatalities from the game this scene
actually pulls from the game itself but
instead of Mortal Kombat 2 we have a
cabinet for the in Universe fighter
called the turning and that is the
character Angel knives and Ali describes
her fatality much in the same way that
she does for mylina here would you play
this before
you ever play this one
I had a friend who knew everything about
this game no
but I had a friend that knew everything
about this game this is one character
named Melina who takes off her mask and
she has monster teeth and then she
swallows you whole and Barks out your
bones
apparently there's this character called
Angel knives who'd
ah what was it
she'd punch a hole through your stomach
before kicking your head off
I'm never a big fan of these things
I wish I could play it
obviously Warner Brothers on the rights
to Mortal Kombat and with him owning HBO
as well they probably gave them that
sweet sweet corporate Synergy deal so
we're not registered to talking about
this although the original Last of Us
game didn't contain a poster for the
game the Remake did and they obviously
released that fully aware that it would
feature in the show I will discuss more
on our super spoiler section how this
arcade cabinet could pop up again so
make sure you stay locked until the end
if you've completed the games now we
learn Joel hasn't been out this way in a
couple of years and later on we
discovered that he only went out there
once in the game Joel had never actually
been out of Bill's Town personally so
I'm going out there was a bit of a
desperate move Ali heads out into the
back room man you eagle-eyed viewers
might spot a safe code up beside the
door this reads one zero nine two five
zero which I Googled to see if it was a
code used in the game unfortunately it's
not and I think this is just an Easter
egg to the codes you'd find dotted about
the game that would lead to upgrades and
extra ammo in the back Ellie discovers
their own secret with there being a door
that leads into the stores basement now
in there she finds some things that
you'd normally run into the game like
lockers and filing cabinets with them
usually having items lying in them I'll
then find some Tampax but she's
interrupted by the sound of an infected
here we find someone trapped under the
rubble with a fungus growing out of the
top part of their head this is
completely grown out of one of their
eyes and as the clicker showed the
cordyceps attached to the brain and then
grow up from there the brain of course
controls the body so doing this allows
them to alter our behaviors and desires
once it grew out it ended up eating the
eyes and those further along in the
infection chain ended up blind like the
clickers are now in our first video we
discussed how the creative team wanted
the infected to seem almost sympathetic
there were times when you'd find them in
a corner sobbing away to themselves when
you think about it having a parasite
bury its way into your brain is a
horrifying thing to experience and this
idea of them being tortured Souls is
definitely apparentier this guy probably
came down here to hide out and either
the roof caved in or he became infected
and then it happened I don't think we
can show because it monetization but Ali
Cuts him open and we see how his flash
has very much become the plant he then
takes Mercy on him by ending his
suffering and Joel stashes his assault
rifle like I said last week I've always
thought of him more as a pistol and
shotgun guy and with it not being much
Emma in the wild for it it's completely
pointless carrying it I let him stashing
it here is important and it also ties
into why he doesn't take any of Bill's
guns Jill believes he's returning here
and he still sees Ellie as a job rather
than being a person this letter at the
end could have some effect on him and it
may end up changing the way he looks at
the world this video is sponsored by
manscaped Valentine's Day is almost upon
us so why not treat a loved one or
yourself to the gift that will get your
boys ready downstairs for that special
occasion I'd like to propose February
13th is National shavier balls day who's
with me don't make too much noise but
listen to this amazing deal with our
amazing exclusive offer we're going to
give you 20 off and free shipping and
all you have to do is go to manscape.com
heavy spoilers and then a heavy spoilers
at the checkout the package comes with
the lawnmower 4.0 it's got Advanced Skin
safe technology a 4000k LED light so you
can light up your face as you're shaving
it's waterproof as well and you can also
travel lock it so when you're on the go
it's not going to set off and waste the
battery it's got the weed whacker as
well that's a nose into your hair
trimmer can you showing away gets the
dirtiest longest hairs in your nose and
yeah I definitely recommend this if
you've got a bit of a big snow like me
now no Platinum package is complete
without this amazing bundle of hygiene
products this includes manscape's
premium body wash the two in one shampoo
body and ball deodorant and much more
infused with aloe vera and sea salt this
always leaves me feeling fresh after a
shower and I definitely recommend you
pick this up if you want to just stay
fresh hygienic all through the day and
don't forget Jen's no day is complete
without manscape signature cologne your
balls any lady will thank you and all
you have to do is go to manscape.com
heavy spoilers and enter the code heavy
spoilers at the checkout I've left a
link in the description below if you
want to go over there right now and
check it out and all you have to do is
go to manscape.com heavy spoilers and
enter heavy spoilers at the checkout
I'll get you 20 off free shipping you're
gonna love it just in time for
Valentine's Day and who wouldn't be
celebrating the times of love with this
amazing Last of Us episode I'll see you
in the next part of the video and huge
shout outs to manscaped again now they
come across a downed plane which Ellie
of course hasn't seen before she's lived
her entire life in the QC and it wasn't
exactly Turkish Airlines promising
flights to Gotham in Metropolis this
reminded me a lot of the scene from
Steven Spielberg's War of the Worlds
when the characters came across
something similar Ali is fascinated by
people getting to go up in the sky but
Joe points out the tragedy in it and his
life was of course massively Changed by
one the opening of episode 1 had the
scientists talking about how disease
could travel fast enough due to
airplanes and one crash down taking out
Joel Tommy and also Sarah's ride
I dreamed about flying the other night
oh yeah
so I'm on this big plane full of people
and everyone is screaming and yelling
because the plane's going down
so I walked the cockpit opened the door
there's no pilot
I try to use the controls but
I obviously have no clue how to fly a
plane
right before we crash
I wake up
I've never been on a plane
isn't that weird
well you know dreams are weird
now the meaning of this is difficult to
descend but I do think that it gives
insight to her character Ali thought she
was a passenger on a plane and that
someone was in control and also guarding
her this could be represented by fedra
who raised her Marlene who was actually
looking after her and then Joel who of
course took care of her now these
figures in her life could be
representative of the pilots but I
personally think that they represent the
passengers the playing goes crashing
down and this is mirroring the fall of
the world around her she gets up to see
there's no pilot and then this shows
that no one is actually in control and
those are the passengers are unable to
fly the plane because no one really
knows what they're doing I think growing
up at all kids yeah they think adults
have got their [__] together and then
when they become one they realize that
no one actually knows what's going on
which I think this conversation could be
signaling
friend
Ellie asks about how the entire world is
stabilized and she talks about people
sitting in restaurants finding Dandy and
then the first bite happening this was
something that we sort of seen play out
last week with a bill ratna being picked
up by the government in a restaurant
before she was taken to examine a bite
victim Ali beta was actually monkeys who
spread the disease and this might be
another 28 Days Later now what I also
think they could be setting up here is
something coming down the line although
we will say before you know by now for
the super spoiler section super super
super exclusive now Joel talks about the
best theory for how they managed to
spread so easily and this is something
that was also touched upon last week he
correctly guesses that the cordyceps
mutated and they somehow got into the
food supply last week we heard how they
changed to the flower and grain Factory
which we discovered acted as the perfect
substrate this in technical terms
assuming it has specific enzymes that
plants can live on and here a change
before spreading out further if it got
into the processing units in the factory
then it could spread into bread and
cereal which would then be eaten by
people across the planet I really hope
this notion carries on throughout the
season and I'd love it if we went to a
store and saw the shelves picked there
except for the cereal and bread aisle
thank God it didn't infect the toilet
paper because we all know how people
love to grab that now Jill remembers the
specific day that happened which was on
a Friday September 26th is because it
was of course his birthday but beyond
that it's also day Sarah died now
further up The Path they come across
several skeletons the game would have
the odd scene like this with red and
blue clothing standing out amongst the
corpses we never really know what
happened at these places in the game but
Joel fills us in on them how much heck
what happened with him and Sarah these
were gunned down by soldiers but the
difference here is that they promised
safety at a qz if there wasn't room
they'd take people into the countryside
and fire upon them and I think this
scene could be taking inspiration from
the ending of The Great Escape this is
also assuming it was carried out in the
Holocaust and later on Bill even
describes the government as being Nazis
and the government are all Nazis the
government are all Nazis well yeah now
but not then also with a Great Escape
swear if someone's kicking off in the
comments about spoilers for that I'm
gonna go mental it's been out 60 years
Joel says that they were killed so that
they couldn't pass on the infection but
I have other theories about why this was
done people rebelled against Federer and
scorning a group like this could
potentially lead to an uprising for
example if they promised safety at the
qz and then said you couldn't come in
It's Gonna annoy a lot of people and it
could lead to some backlash and we then
take focus on a rainbow blanket and a
child's body which takes us into our
major flashback for the episode I love
how the series has done this and every
episode so far has had a major part of
the past filled in with elements that
weren't present in the game we had a
scientist predicting the rise of the
cordyceps which was then mirrored by one
coming across the discovery of the first
captured infected now we're seeing what
happened to the survivors days after the
outbreak and this is all new stuff to
show us exactly what it was like X's are
painted on doors and in the game you'd
often come across these houses warning
you not to enter in the game you
actually found a note to a secret stash
hidden by hunters that was marked with
an X so if you're playing through the
game right now then make sure you look
out for that one every single person is
being given a mandatory evacuation
notice and we see this in front of a
civil war Monument along with fighting
against the infected The Last of Us is
also Batman vs Man and this brother
versus brother Monument could be heading
towards that this sign also popped up in
the game and when he entered Lincoln you
could spot it in the middle of the
street the irony is they'd actually be
safer in the town as they end up being
killed when they could have lived out
the rest of their lives here in the game
you could see how dangerous Lincoln was
due to being overrun by infected and
here I was kind of thinking I don't know
why Joel and Tess didn't just stay here
Bill kind of shuts down the idea but
it's way better than the qz and I'm sure
that you know a couple more bottles of
wine they could have convinced him it
was a good idea anyway at this point
we're introduced to Belle played by Nick
Offerman we see him surveilling the tan
through CCTV and he's very much an end
of the welder actually used to work with
a woman whose son thought doomsday was
coming and apparently spent years
collecting tins of beans little did he
know it was toilet roll toilet roll he
needed horde as they're bloody take
they're taking it all get it quick
now they really recaptured the look of
Belle and along with his trusted shotgun
he looks pretty identical to the game
he's got weapons lining the wall and
collections of guns and I'm a magazine
along with a machete this weapons how
he's introduced in the game with him
cutting off the head of an infected
that's got Joel on the ground he ends up
donning his gas mask which he also wore
in that and we see his bunkers cleverly
located beneath the chest of drawers
love seeing the gas masks back which is
something he too worn the PlayStation
counterpart as we know those spores have
been removed from the series to the
creative team worrying that everyone
would be asking why they aren't
constantly done in gas masks again I I
don't think people would have cared but
it could have also been for the budget
or to see the actors faces as they're
terrified by The Infected a Bill's room
also has some really cool details in it
we have his computer and can tell by the
blue background that is actually running
Windows 2000 I had to double check
whether that was Windows XP but that had
those luscious luscious Green Hills
whereas this is more let's say plane it
shows Bill's focus and how he's not
interested in Thrills I think anyway
later on we also see this room has a
workbench in it he's pulled directly
from the game and they're what players
use to upgrade their weapons also forgot
to mention last week that we actually
had another nod to the game when Tess
and Joel went into their backpack they
swung them off their shoulders and got
on the ground just like how she old does
every time he wants to craft something
there's also the magazines that we see
throughout the episode in the game these
were used for upgrade trees and they
helped you unlock special skills now as
Bill comes out of the ground we can also
see that he has a wine rack and he raids
a wine store letter showing how much it
means to him when he serves a bottle to
Frank Frank is played by Murray Bartlett
and you might recognize him as playing
Armand in the White Lotus he's a
complete opposite Bell now we can see
this in many ways bill is kind of out of
shape and this is seen later on when the
pair go jogging together this actually
speaks to their time in the apocalypse
as Bill's been kicking his feet up and
living it up whereas Frank has been
fighting to survive out there it's
pretty much survival of the fittest
meanwhile bills in a safe place where
it's 1.40ish per gallon of of gas
you know take me there take me back
now we see that Bill's door has an
accident with markings around it like
the one before these are pulled from the
game but they've also appeared in real
life and during Hurricane Katrina they
could be found on doors these denote how
many are inside which team searched it
and the date that they did we can also
see that Bell's House was built circus
1793 which makes it from pre-civil War
era this further adds to his old school
Persona and how he doesn't trust the
government he's a regular old Ron
Swanson who loves guns and hates the New
World Order anyway the town is
completely empty now and we get a sort
of last man on Earth situation with them
basically being able to do what he wants
montages like this are a staple of
post-apocalyptic movies and most
famously I remember the one from the
Dawn of the Dead it went on a shopping
spree in the mall but it's also selling
it popped up in 28 Days Later with them
going into the supermarket and just
going well with all the food now this is
to the backdrop of the song yes I'm
Coming Home by Fleetwood Mac it makes it
really a beat and I think the entire
point of Bella's story is a show that
you can have fun and find love even in
the apocalypse Tess and Joel were a
couple but they never really seemed like
they were in love and instead I think
the apocalypse pushed them together so
they had safety in numbers Joel has
completely shut himself off and to me
the stuff with Bill and Frank could be a
reflection of how he needs to open up a
bill takes a speed boat fills up several
barrels of petrol and goes while at Home
Depot this is to build his traps which
we did end up in carrying in the game
when you first entered Lincoln normally
you'd be walking along would notice a
tripwire which you'd then have to set
off either by luring in an infected or
throwing a brick at it Bill eventually
gave his traps and shotgun a Joel when
he entered his home and I love dropping
these things throughout the game you
know just a little trick for them now an
infected Setter one later by pulling a
trap by it and bill says it doesn't get
all you're definitely right and yeah
take me back to that game and the first
thing he does is secure the area get
some alcohol and build a generator to
power the town he's created a nice
little life for himself and his during
this time that he ends up meeting Frank
a bell really was someone who was used
to being alone and people who prepare
for the apocalypse tend to do so by
themselves it's rarely a group ever
because it requires paranoia and
shutting oneself off in order to survive
Frank shows that he should open up to
people though and if it wasn't for him
then he'd never know Tess and Joel four
years later we hear the song White Room
by Cream which has a lot of meaning that
applies to the episode the song is about
someone stuck in a white room by
themselves and here they face depression
and also loneliness bill of course as a
White House and is murdered by most of
the buildings he's walled himself up
from everything and know he's alive he's
not really living for anything this
reminds me a lot of Alexandria from The
Walking Dead but there's no other people
around and therefore it's not really the
rest of civilization and the homie is a
poster for don't tread on me and this
also brings a lot of meaning with it Not
only was it a Metallica song but it was
also a political slogan used in the
American Revolution it dates all the way
back to the Bible and in Latin phrases
this means do not touch me and it was
said by Jesus to marry Magdalene after
his resurrection the bomb between
physical and spiritual was at its
highest during this point and it came
across more as a warning to it I think
it's more in line with a Metallica song
as it's the same as the cover that was
used and that song Had lyrics like Give
me liberty or give me death the Royal
snake imagery was inspired by Benjamin
Franklin who said that the animal was a
great symbol for the American Spirit
anyway a trap is triggered and out in
the Holy dug Bell finds Frank believing
it's its own trap bill is immediately
suspicious and in the game it was
difficult to not immediately have
paranoia when he came across someone you
he says that he set out from Baltimore
qz which we learn is now more now we
never visit this location in the game
with the characters instead heading more
in a Northern direction of Pittsburgh
according to Google Maps it's a six day
walk non-stop between Baltimore and
Boston so we can't see why Frank's lost
so many out on the road Bill decides to
take him in and this all happens after
using a scanner to get the all clear now
they have dinner together and Bill ends
up feeding him rabbit these were animals
the characters had to hunt in the game
because obviously yeah the farm
industry's gone it's a complete opposite
to what he's just gone through and the
man's been out on the road facing
certain death and I was sipping wine and
eating rabbit he takes to the piano and
here he plays a song a long long time by
Linda Ronstadt this contains lyrics like
I can see I'm gonna love you for a long
long time which is something he sounds
terrible dude you sound terrible mate
you sound terrible but it does play in
the episode now Bill takes to it instead
and he manages to sing it perfectly it
kinda sums up the pair I think with one
being chaotic Razia there is highly
ordered in control the lyrics of course
Summit the relationship that they're
about to be in and for the next 45
minutes we see the rest of their lives
play out bill is different in the game I
think because he's way more open or as
in the last diversity he looks down on
Joe for caring about people and in this
world that sort of shit's good for one
thing getting you killed
so you know what it did wasn't the [__]
up and I realized it's got to be just me
we never really see his relationship
with Frank and I have spoken to people
who play the game without even picking
up on it at all Frank wasn't ever
someone that we actually met but this
episode in juxtaposition of that
completely develops their relationship
now it is of course share similarities
with his game counterpart like how he
kicks off about Resource Management why
he does that in the final letter too and
we find out that he's the one who
reached out to Tess and Joel they come
over forgotten party in Belle's thesis
is a bad idea further diving into how
closed off he is from Humanity he brings
a gun to the dinner table and Joel says
we can help each other and get that gun
out of my face
this of course goes beyond just being
cautious and the pair of course both
ready to flip at a moment's notice if
this situation calls for it they're left
alone and Joel offers to get more
material to make the fence last the rest
of their lives together in the game it
was clear Tess was more the point of
contact which is why Joel will never
visited Lincoln personally a Tess and
Frank talk about using the radio again
but they decide to use a code in case
anyone's listening in as we know from
episode 1 this becomes the 60s 70s and
80s music which also plays in a what
they discover at the end now Jill warns
that Raiders will eventually swarm the
town and after Frank makes a strawberry
garden we see this playing out in the
night reminded me a lot of I Am Legend
and keeping out Raiders is something
that's too mirrored in the game but
moving through Lincoln you actually only
ever encounter the infected because
Bill's got such a tight leash on
everything after being shot Bell tiles
Frank to call Joel as he's someone like
him who's able to take care of weaker
people this is of course why he was
entrusted with Ellie and we very much
have this Dynamic of a strong Survivor
protecting a week LS equipped one Bell
survives though and in a twist of fate
Frank is left in the wheelchair we then
jump to 2023 and finally catch up with
the present both are in their winter
years now and we can see that Frank has
spent a lot of time painting this is
important too as it shows that the
better side of humanity like art and
agriculture haven't died out in the
desperation he's trying to paint bill
but Judah losing his motor functions he
now can't do it what about we do close
out with a penny of him which pretty
much sums up the love of his life now
these really subtle moments like Bill
giving a wing to Frank as he paints him
and watering the flowers for the last
time and at this point you could be
forgiven for thinking where not even in
a zombie apocalypse show Bill wakes up
to find that Frank has decided this will
be his last day but rather than
wallowing in it they decide to make the
most of it the pair get married and have
dinner together and Frank wants to take
his pills that he can fade away into the
night we hear the song on the nature of
daylight and having just covered [__]
Island in arrival for the channel I
think the creative team were inspired by
those two films both use the piece with
I think probably the latter lending
itself better to what's going on here
I'd only get two spoilery on it but the
end of the movie is about embracing the
beauty of life no matter how
heartbreaking it is which is also
reflected in this scene as well the pair
have what could be a very painful day
ahead of them but instead they're using
it as a way to celebrate their life
without dwelling on the sadness of death
that we're all gonna face one day now
from here they share rabbit and drink
the same wine that they had on the first
day they met bill then reveals that he's
decided to go out with Frank rather than
continue living now this is a complete
180 on his original feelings when the
outbreak first happened whereas
originally he wanted to survive by
himself here we see that he's grown to
the point he'd rather not live if it
meant he lost Frank at this point we
hear a song from the game that also
happens at an emotional moment in it
we'll talk about this later on in a
super spoiler section but it's very much
used in the context to show that not
everything is Bleak I think you kind of
need this moment to breathe in a show
like this as the last diversity egg it
can be pretty depressing so it's nice to
have this balance of like look there is
still some good early and you'll arrive
at Lincoln to find the flowers starting
to die and the food on the table has
started mold she plays some notes on the
piano echoing the earlier scene and
finds a letter which mirrors the one
from the game yeah though it's a lot
more positive without Landing their
lives together we learned they laid down
and went to sleep and again I got some
flashes of 28 Days Later in that gym
goes home to discover his parents have
done something similar but they showed
it there whereas a letter wants them not
to go into the bedroom now it's
addressed directly to Joe and bill says
that though he hated the world there was
one person worth saving he's talking
about Tessier but now that position has
of course shifted to Ellie who he's
gonna go on protecting we get a focus on
the sentence about keeping tests safe
which is pretty devastating because
Jill's of course failed to do this
instead of confronting the grief though
he immediately leaves and takes his mind
off it by crumpling up the ladder just
this in the same way that this part of
the game ends we get a scene in which
they discover the truck and left at the
front Joel also checks the fridge which
has sulfuric acid in it Joel asks to see
her arm and this could be teasing at
somehow we'll discuss so no spoilers
because I'll get i'll get tons of
comments but super small section now in
the basement we discover why there was
80's music playing on the radio at the
end of episode 1. Bill had it set up so
that if he didn't reset the countdown
then it was just gonna play 80s
constantly on a loop this would of
course signal that they were in danger
and will get Tess and Gerald to come out
to where they were now it is possible
that bill knew this would happen anyway
which is why he of course addressed
solar energy Joel I do have a quick
Through Time new Time new time so Joel
and Tess they'd been searching
desperately for a car battery so that
they could get to Tommy originally in
the game they sell guns to Robert but
the whole thing in the show revolved
around getting a battery for a truck
bill of course has one and I think that
he might have had the 80s music on Loop
so that they were gonna come out looking
for him he left down the keys for the
truck because he possibly knew that they
needed one and thus this is very much
his last bill and testament to give them
with the ride that they've been looking
for anyway that's in a few time and we
can see Ellie sorry you have to let that
[Music]
dude
sorry I have to let it play out who
don't you don't
right as I was saying
right as I was saying the pair get some
clothes and Ellie slips into the red
t-shirt that she wore throughout the
game she also finds a handgun and I
believe it's the same model as the one
she carries in the source material Jill
gifts to her a NAB but here she takes it
behind his back which might cause some
issues later on gel comes out finally
wearing the green checkered shirt that
he does throughout the majority of this
story and you might have noticed Frank
wearing this earlier in the episode they
get in the car together and originally
in the game he had a much tensor scene
in which you had to jump start it Jill
and Bill had to push it as the infected
swarmed them whilst Ellie sat in the
ride attempting to pop the clutch love
the little touch of her not knowing to
wear a seatbelt and together they head
out as she discovers a tape in the glove
box no points for guessing what the song
is and we watch them right out to Linda
ronsten's long long time we close out to
an open window with a picture of Bill
hanging up which takes us into our super
super spoiler section now for this bit I
will be talking about elements that
appear in both games Beyond ended well
one of them's an ending runer but there
are some moments in Easter eggs in the
episode so that will probably spoil
things down the line if you're out at
this point I'd really love you guys if
you hit the thumbs up on the way out and
make sure you subscribe to not miss our
breakdowns in episode 4. thanks right
what a [__] [__] I play the games
well that bloody hell is wrong with you
anyway the open window has a lot of big
moments in the game it's the menu screen
for the first one and in part two it's
also the last shot as Ellie walks away
that summed up the end of her story and
here it's very much summing up the
ending of Bill and Frank's the Mortal
Kombat 2 cabinet is pretty important as
well and I think it's something that's
going to return in the series later on
it ties in massively with the Riley
story and in the DLC left behind you
played on the Turning cabinet alongside
Riley my guess is that they'll do
something similar on the Riley flashback
and have them imagining what it's like
to play Mortal Kombat 2 wasting money
getting their asses kicked by scorpion
now on the road Ellie also discusses
monkey and how she bears that they
spread the cordyceps monkeys actually
show up in the game how we end up
encountering them when we enter the
universe city turns out the fireflies
were experimenting on them to find a
cure to them being so close to us on a
DNA level might not have been a
connection to that but with monkeys
potentially appearing down the line I
thought I'd bring that line up and the
sulfuric acid could also be something as
well with that being administered in the
series in part two when Ellie and Dina
bunker down she ends up showing her her
arm we discover that Ellie did a
chemical burn on the bite using sulfuric
acid and this was then covered up with a
tattoo once it healed other got sick of
constantly having to hide her arm so she
carried this out once it became clear
that The Cure thing wasn't gonna pan out
and also tying with part two we get what
could be a nod to the spaceship scene in
that oh he talks about the car being
like a spaceship and in part two she all
takes la2 museum for a birthday here
they climb into an Apollo vessel and
then Ellie imagines what it's like
traveling into space anyway that wraps
up the breakdown and I think this
episode kind of transcended the
Apocalypse to tell a Love's story this
is something that's been at the heart of
the show and in the official social
podcast for episode 1. they said that
the show was very much going to be
discussing the positives and negatives
of Love yeah it's a more wholesome
Outlook but in the case of Joel and
Ellie we see how dangerous it is Joel
begins to love Ellie like she's his own
daughter and because of this he Dooms
Humanity by killing the fireflies in
order to save her life so we have this
idea that love can be a good thing but
also that it has its negatives as well
especially if someone stands in the way
of it I think this was important to
explore with Bill and Frank and it'll
probably massively influence the future
episodes even if it's not obvious now
it's a big deviation from the game so
whether people prefer that or not is
gonna be something I think they're gonna
be going back and forth over I I think
this stuff in the game works better as a
level because you travel through the
graveyard the school and then you fight
a blower in it kind of rams up to your
boss which I think works in a game and
the show kind of really needed to do
something different so they focused on
character development gave us a bit of a
breather so it wasn't all doom and gloom
and they also managed to make one of the
Sidecar characters way more fleshed out
I enjoyed it and so far I think we've
had three really really strong episodes
I know there's kind of back and forth at
the moment but let me know your thoughts
below and again thank you for rocking
with me we are in a competition right
now giving away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on the screen right
now so that's you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if nothing
else to watch we've got another Last of
Us video on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this without the way thank you for
clicking on the video I've been Paul you
enjoy the rest of your night or day or
week and I'll see you next time take
care peace